oh gosh nineties crazes I tried the
bangs they always had to be perfect some
high-waisted jeans obviously go to the
mall the running man for sure this was
1997 this is on the set of full house I
want to show people that I met the door
I was not at a rave I'm I went to a
Catholic High School and this was our
retreat this was my favorite outfit by
the way you know it's it's super fun to
kind of go back to this time when I was
16 oh gosh are you ready for the oh I'm
not nobody's ready oh no this is
bringing me back we got some overalls
yes and then a little earring I actually
think I was wearing these with earrings
got this top and it's got the drop
please like so cuentas and it's Berlin
Ivy's move goodness this look
a little scared a moment oh god it's so
great it was the details you know what I
mean the roll up in this and the roll
down of the socks Wow okay let's do this
let's do this I don't want to go back
but let's do this where's my blow pop oh
wow I feel like I am back in the 90s
this is like my moment of being at the
full house set and a little little
awkward and weird but you know this will
be fun
okay we can just do a couple just for
fun of like okay like you know we're
gonna come a little off and be right
here yes face a little more towards me
right there like that I feel like it's
is it left foot up and I had that goofy
smile - what am i doing I'm such a nerd
bucket oh that's hard to get a happy
face - oh my guys we did it
I definitely feel a little childlike and
young like I'm 16 again kind of brings
me back to like remembering what that
trip was like with my mom and you know
coming to LA for the first time I'm
pleasantly surprised at how comfortable
these overalls are oh my gosh
side-by-side Oh God but what's the
terrible look at she this is her mom
there we are
think every little girl dreams of
something this picture really was like
the first start of all of that now
there's some things that are just really
good just left
left behind and I think art one of them
don't forget to watch Hollywood darlings
Wednesday's 8 p.m. on pop
[Music]